the week of february 15th
what day of the week and where we're
still working on
but
and that is to accommodate the fact that
early bills are due by the february 10th
those are the bills going to second
committees
so we have to have a
[Music]
session to vote on those bills for him
to go
to the second committee
the second piece is and i sent you all
what the
the house chief of staff sent out about
how to find out where
online all of the
um
submitted testimony from members of the
public is going and how to to find it
and look at it i suggest that we do that
on a fairly frequent basis
it is not all going to be downloaded and
printed
um at this point anyways
so
[Music]
please do that because we're already
beginning to get
submitted testimony on house bill 2022
which is the 10-year plan
from regional planners and cities and
the rest so
please look at at those and read them as
they're coming in i appreciate it
thank you
and good morning
i'd like to
to begin
house bill 1040
establishing a commission to study
revenue alternatives to the road toll
for electric powered and hybrid vehicles
for the funding of improvements to the
state's highways and bridges
and their resulting improvements to the
environment
with that i would like to call the
the prime sponsor
representative norman major
and
representative major welcome to public
works
thank you mr
chairman i'm here
i'm my name is representative
major i represent rockingham 14 the
towns of atkinson and plasto
and glad to be here again
i'm here to introduce house bill
establishing a commission to study
revenue alternatives to the road toll
for electric power and hybrid vehicles
for the funding of improvements to the
state highway and bridges and for the
i have two handouts
for you today one's a narrative which is
a word document and the other is a
series of slides
the series of slides is similar to
what's been passed out to you in the
past
and the only difference is i had added
the last five slides which is the result
of the 250 thousand dollar
study
match with toll credits that was done
at the end of 2019
and then into 2020 on this particular
road just
uses fee
i don't plan to go through these
that but i
and
bringing up the date
on the slides
three to four
essentially
talks about the source of revenues for
the highway fund
and the main source is the road toll and
the next one is the registration
and then there was a lot of other little
things gimmicks and things like that in
order to be able to support the highway
and
slide
essentially
told what the
fleet
miles per gallon were
as it
changed from 2007 to 2017
it's gone up to an average of about 25
miles a gallon gallon
when you consider the entire
population
slide number
nine
is the cost of construction we must
remember that every year it costs more
to do the same amount of work whether
it's maintaining or building or
repairing
10 to 14.
and you've heard that before it's the
condition
and status of the roads and bridges
in both the state and municipalities in
14 is i find rather important because
the last part of on 14
that tells the number of bridges that we
have
aged 75 years of age or older
and quite high for both the state and
15 is what
have been our options to resolve
the high funding to the highway fund
you know we could continue doing nothing
or we could raise the gas tax
and then i think you'll see
the result of the
study that was done
that
just raising the gas tax is not
equitable to everybody
we could appropriate more money from the
general fund but
go ahead and try
i mean you have just recently but
the general fund
isn't
doesn't appreciate that
we could form another study commission
which i'm asking you to
because the study commissions that we've
had in the past
have indicated that we need to do
something about the highway fund
but in all of this
we ignored one thing
and that is the
environment and we we need to get the
environments on board
to support this
because as you can see as we go through
especially the last five figures
five last five slides why it's so
important
that we get the environments on board
because it will
slide 19
is essentially
at new hampshire
the miles the average miles driven
in 2014 was 12 900 miles
and why that's important in
my studies here
or my proposal i use an average of 12
driver
slide 20 to 22 essentially the road
users free contact
concept
it shows the
the number of vehicles that we have in
uh
as of
we had
seven million vehicles
about 650 000 in the next category 20 to
30 000
20 to 30 miles per gallon
and then it drops off dramatically at 30
to 40 65 thousand
forty to fifty twelve thousand and
greater than fifty fifteen hundred and
no gasoline or essentially all electric
it also shows that
on the road usage fee
it into slots so that
20 miles or less
paid 10
or between 20 and 30 they paid 25
and etc
a total of 26 million dollars collected
and when you subtract what's retained
by the
agent
which is one dollar
for registration you have 25 000
and then you have to subtract twelve pro
twelve percent which goes back to the
municipalities
20 will show you
after you pay the 3 million dollars to
the municipality you'll have 22 million
dollars left
which will be the net to the highway
fund for roads and bridges
and then this just
shows to the right of that shows what
happens 22 23 and 24
with a minor increases
now if you go to
which is the new one
and this is the result of the
quarter of a million dollar study
that was done
in the end of 19 and into 20.
it shows and it was done on the road
usage fee concept
that was
explained in this
handout
that
if you continue doing nothing
that you can see a drop off in the
highway
that would vary from about
118 million dollars to about 94 million
dollars
but with the road usage fee
and they did an analysis on the makeup
of the
vehicle population to do this
this is what their estimates came up on
which is about 20 something million
dollars higher than it was in 2020
and it maintains that
level
out to 2030.
and if you look at that
associated taking into cost of living
so it'll still be dropping
but it doesn't drop down to 2020 level
but what the fee
what the study showed
is that in the next slide where it says
annual
fuel plus
road usage fee cost at various miles per
gallon level
at 20 at 12 000 miles per year
and this is with
gas
at two dollars and sixty-two cents a
gallon
where today it's 320.
that
person at 20 miles per gallon
would be spending about seventeen
hundred dollars
to to travel that and gas and road usage
fee
at thirty miles a gallon
something under twelve hundred dollars
at forty
around almost 900 dollars
an electric vehicle
you would pay the 125 road usage fee
plus the cost of electricity
and how does the annual fuel
plus the
road uses feed costs
varies at various miles per gallon level
and this is
showing the 262 a gallon not the 320 a
gallon right now
and so that you can see how
how it varies
tremendously
and the poor guy
that
has a 20 miles per gallon
is going to be paying
if you're talking
320 i mean 260 versus
a gallon on 600 gallons that's a lot of
money
and then the
last slide shows the average annual fuel
tax plus the road usage fee
on
different categories
the roof of the fuel tax of 125 dollars
and then
that will drop down because at
twenty to thirty you're
buying less fuel so you're going to be
paying a larger use uses fee but this
shows the equity
of whether you have a
completely
[Music]
non-combustible engine
or an electric engine with no gas
that they're paying about the same
amount of money
to support the roads and bridges
where right now if you have a complete
electric vehicle you're paying nothing
to support the roads
but one other important thing
page five of the
this is what we've forgotten
this is the energy related carbon
dioxide emission by sectors
from 1990 through 2050
and you can see that
prior to 2020
most of the time
electric generation power
was the
culprit which had the largest amount of
emissions
and transportation wasn't far behind
but now since 2020 transportation is
going to be the leader
emitter
emissions
and
because we're
going off from coal and going to
natural gas and doing other things
that has dropped
now considerably as far as the total pot
goes
but this is extremely important
this is why we need to get the
environmentalists
to support
this so called road users fee or
something similar to it
in order if
they want to work towards cleaning up
now
you can stop me anytime but now what i
want to do is go to the narrative
the narrative is kind of repeats a
little bit what i said
yeah the road uses fee was designed to
counteract the drop in the highway fund
the next bullet
the objective of the fee is to make up
for the state highway trust fund revenue
that's lost because of
the efficiency of vehicles
the next one is
in 2019 we were awarded the 250 000
grant
and and that was
match with turnpike toll credits to do
and then a primary look at the study
projected the gas tax revenue raised in
of
128.5 million would decline to 93.4
million by 2030.
a decline of 35.1 million dollars
20 27
reduction without the lower juices fee
the proposed road uses fee according to
the study would collect about 28.5
million starting in 2021
with
growing to 49.9 million in 2030
which is a
21.4 million increase
well the gas tax reduces 35 million
dollars
using the current trends
the combined fuel plus road uses fee for
2030 would generate 143 million an
increase of
149.9 million
vehicles not fueled by gasoline would
pay a flat fee of 125
while all others would pay a graduated
fee based on the fuel economy rating
the schedule of fees begins with a base
vehicle with a fuel economy rating of 20
miles per gallon and i've explained this
shows the first figure
savings versus 20 miles per gallon
and today's
cost gas at 320 a gallon
12 000 miles 20 miles per gallon you'd
buy 600 gallons of gas pay 1920 dollars
with 10 dollar road usage
fee and the total cost would be nineteen
hundred and thirty dollars
if you have a fifty miles per gallon
vehicle
your total cost would be eight hundred
and forty three dollars
that 50 miles per gallon vehicle
would save you over a thousand dollars
of operating versus the 20 miles per
gallon
you'd pay 125
which is a savings of 1805 versus the
20.
now
i've heard a number of times people
telling me
that you go to if you have to pay a road
usage fee you're penalizing
the guy so he's not going to buy the
vehicle
but when you look at this graphs that i
showed you
how much they or just look at this how
much they the total cost 125 dollars
versus
1900 for 20 miles per gallon vehicle and
even more for less
to me
the next figure
has to do with
and
we converted it
to a road usage fee
and we're not
with the number of light vehicles we
have today
and if all these light vehicles
were converted
to electric
versus the 110 million dollars
as we do today
which is a
million dollar increase
to me these are the highlights you
what i want to do on
five
i've listed what's happening today
around us
most major domestic foreign automa
makers have announced plans to expand
production of electric vehicles in the
coming decade
therefore adding to the miles per gallon
increase
that study we just had
done for a quarter of a million dollars
it's going to be hit hard with this
because
it's going to accelerate
the
more
efficient vehicles
as shown by these other articles wall
street journal
august
21 electric vehicle start-up large stone
motors
is to start limited truck production in
september
financial times in august of 21.
wholesale delivers of new engine
vehicles in china
including battery-powered plug-in
hybrids and hydrogen fuel cars jumped
164 percent year on year
and they represent 10 percent of the
the wall street journal article
in august of 21
volkswagen has quantum scape
racing to build a cheaper battery that
utilizes solid solid-state technology
and not the lithium-ion technology
which
less combustible and safer
china
on
an article financial times august 21
is the largest battery producer
has unveiled a cell that runs on lithium
not on lithium but on sodium a cheap
abundant material that can be extracted
from salt
so these things are happening
wall street journal
may of 21. ford raises goals for
electric autos and will boost spending
by 30 billion dollars by 2020
on expanding production of electric
vehicles
wall street journal june of 21 general
motors increased spending to 35 billion
on production of electric autos and
add two more battery plants in the
united states
july of 21 global automaker steli this
plans to spend more than 35 billion by
2025 on array of new plug-in models
fiat chrysler automobiles france's psa
group they will establish five battery
factories in north america and europe
and they will certify all 14 brands jeep
ram
few
i can't really say
going to all electric
wall street journal july of 21 some of
the world's biggest car companies are
sending their combustion engine to scrap
heap and are pouring billions of dollars
in electric motors and battery factories
instead of powertrain specialists
they're hiring thousands of software
engineers and battery experts
wall street journal july of 21 sale of
plugins had more than doubled in the
first half of 21
and is by tesla
new hampshire union later in august
merchant fleet
is staking his future on electric
vehicles
they've ordered 12 000 of the new ev600
electric delivery vans the biggest order
they'll be manufactured by bright drop a
general motors company
they've also placed a large order for
the next year's ford 150 lightning
electric truck
all toad has orders in place for forty
thousand electric vehicles general
motors announced there are sixty
thousand public
places to charge vehicles and that was
in august of twenty one
but wall street journal
the federal
in august of 21 federal infrastructure
bills proposing spending
7.5 billion dollars on state and
municipalities to build electric
charging stations
and it goes on and on and on
the
the work on batteries
the solid state batteries is coming
along fine so there's a lot of work
going on
that is going to transform this at a
much faster rate than what has been been
projected on those five slides that i
showed you
so
uh
i think we have plenty of ammunition
here to get our environments on board
thank you i'll take any questions
thank you representative
before we take questions from the
committee i just want to note uh
representative i'm always very
appreciative of all the work you've done
over the years
uh work uh that's dear and near to this
uh
this committee and if you ever want to
leave your charge of what you're doing
and come to a new committee we can
probably find you a seat so
with that i can't promise leadership
uh with that uh questions for the
representative
seeing none thank oh i'm sorry yes
representative um so you want this to be
uh study how is
this different than what the new
hampshire department of transportation
i'm not sure what the new hampshire
department of transportation i want this
to be concentrated on the
environments
in order to get their support behind
this
thank you for the question represent
plastic are there any other questions
for the representative
the chairman would like to call steam
member
representative graham to testify
welcome to public works
thank you i've been here a time or two
for the record i'm representative john
graham i represent hillsborough district
7 which is the town of bedford
for the veteran members of this
committee you've heard this before
you know that both representative majors
and i have sponsored
bills that would implement
a road usage fee they have always
lost on the floor they've passed this
committee but they've always lost on the
floor of the house from two wings
those that say oh god no
new taxes or fees can ever be
implemented for any reason
and on the other sp end of the spectrum
of
we're saving the planet why should we
pay more for our electric vehicles
what this proposal is
is to try to come to some kind of common
understanding
that
our
state highway fund
is losing revenue
and as we transition to more
both high high
mileage vehicles um
my car that i own now is a couple years
old it's getting 36 miles to the gallon
you know 15 years ago if you got 20 or
25 you were doing good
and
electric vehicles and other
forms of
energy
are are coming on remember what dot told
us
the other day
is that within the 10-year plan
they have 17 million dollars of federal
funds
to establish
electrical charging infrastructure
within the state
we're planning on it coming but if we're
not going to charge a vehicle that is as
large
and weighs as much
and uses the road as frequently as say a
diesel or gasoline-powered vehicle
then we are
are
[Music]
missing out and we will continue to have
problems with our our highway fund
and and we will get into it
personally i think we should pass
not just this bill but we probably ought
to uh be having a serious discussion
on the future
of how we're going to pay for our roads
in a bill this is good you'll note that
on the bill there is
not just house
but there are senate sponsors who think
that we also begin
we really need to look at this i'm
surprised that the senate would would
come along because they're all going to
be ready for reelection and they usually
don't
um but i i think that it's useful that
we do that
and i i just
yesterday this came as transportation
topics i
they send it to me every week
but but the headline is automated and
electric trucks show progress
so we're not only looking at cars we're
looking at semi-trailers and the rest
maybe not next next year but within 10
years i can see that happening
so i think that we need to do this study
realizing that even if i wanted to turn
this into an implementation plan
that it
probably would found her in the house
and would definitely not pass the the
senate having had some talks over there
so i would urge the committee to
pass
1040 get it to the center senator so
that we can begin
to actually look at
how
in the future we want to fund our
highways
given the fact that modes of
transportation are changing
thank you mr chairman and
i'm not sure how many other cards you
have if anybody has questions they might
want to defer them till i i will answer
questions but
i'm cognizant of there are other people
behind me we only have
a little over 25 minutes to finish the
hearing
um thank you with the
thank you representative graham with
your wish of not accepting
questions
i will but yeah is there anyone
represented faulkner did you want to ask
a question
yes i can try to do this as
constructively as possible uh
understanding all the work you've done
before but
is it within the scope of the study
commission to look at the total
amount that we're getting whether that's
adequate for the future
funding of the uh
of our highway system and
do is within the scope
to look at the equity issue of how many
people
how many miles people drive because this
basically sets a flat fee for
everybody regardless of whether they
drive 50 000 miles or
5 000 miles in a year
um
i i would say that once the commission
meets there is always that caveat of
other you know these
it specifies some things that they
should look at but it also has the
caveat of or any other issues they want
to look at type type of a statement
that's true of any study committee or
commission that
i will say that we have looked in this
committee before about vehicle miles
traveled
we als always run into an issue of am i
traveling in
new hampshire vermont maine the
commonwealth of massachusetts or on a
trip to missouri to see my mother you
know how do you measure the miles that
you travel
if you're going to try to do a miles
traveled tax
it has not gone well in the couple of
states that have tried it
because
even there it's kind of a volunteer with
voluntary pilot programs and they still
ran into the same types of problems of
people not wanting to volunteer because
they go across state lines and the rest
so
um
there would nothing there would be
nothing in this to preclude them looking
at
at altern those types of alternatives
but i think the focus of this study
commission would be on
how do we get equity
with a
say fully electric vehicle
registration fees into the highway fund
and that's it
that's it all
because
you know you and i if we have gas cars
at least pay
eight uh is it 22. yeah
i used to say 18 cents but it's up to 22
what for but
um
cents per the per gallon and remember
that that
last two um
4.2 cents
goes to sunsets in a couple of years and
we dropped back to 18 and a half cents
so again it it's all impetus to to study
how we are going to fund the state
portion of our highway
in the future okay thank you thank you
representative i'm seeing no further
questions
i'd like to note that we only have one
pink card remaining
i see someone someone someone's coming
forward if you want to speak we're going
to need those pink cards and with that i
would like to recognize kelly buchanan
with the clean energy new hampshire
please come forward welcome to public
works it's nice to see you again thank
you it's nice to see you as well
representative mcconkey thank you
members of the committee this morning
for taking my testimony
my name is kelly buchanan and i'm
director of legislative and regulatory
affairs at clean energy new hampshire
and as part of our work at clean energy
new hampshire we do a lot on electric
vehicles we have founded and managed the
initiative called drive electric new
hampshire that's a coalition of
stakeholders interested in evs that come
together to promote the accelerated
adoption of evs and the installation of
things evs need like charging
infrastructure
we do most of this work through
education and outreach
but the transition to electric vehicles
is ever impending we've seen a lot of
movement from manufacturers as well as
policy initiatives at the state level at
the public utilities commission to
establish electric rates that
serve electric vehicle charging as well
and so i come before you this morning in
support of house bill 1040. this really
is the most appropriate approach to
determining a revenue alternative rather
than an immediate implementation road
toll for electric vehicles
here in new hampshire we still have a
very low adoption rate of evs i believe
for my work at the public utilities
commission the numbers range from
you know a couple thousand electric
vehicles registered in the state so far
but i know this is changing for example
our board of directors a majority of
them drive evs or hybrids and a few of
our staff do as well
so this study gives us an opportunity to
address the issue before it becomes an
issue and ensures that we have a
collaborative buy-in from the
stakeholders in this process
a thorough and well-informed study will
aid in consensus to address any
potential shortfalls in the funding of
our highways and bridges because it does
seem quite rational to ensure that
electric vehicles are
contributing to roads as well
so with that i would be glad to take any
of your questions this morning
thank you or thank you are there
questions for
seeing none thank you thank you
my last card that i have is from rebecca
holler if i remember correctly
department of environmental services
in support of the bill
good morning thank you representative
mcconkey uh rebecca ohler department of
environmental services i'm the bureau
administrator for our technical services
bureau which houses our mobile sources
programs
we were a member of the previous
commission that studied this issue and
are happy to see that another commission
is going to be called on this
because we do have changing
changing facts and figures we are now up
to in the neighbor well we haven't done
an analysis of the ev
rates since um
early 2020
or 2020 registrations but we're you know
we're closer in the six to seven
thousand range of plug-in hybrids and
hybrid and electric vehicles
in the state so far
so we are growing it's still a very
small number um
and we look forward to
looking at all of the alternatives for
how we might make an equitable
an equitable program that will allow
everybody to pay their fair share i know
that there are other proposals in
different bills
some that include
annual miles traveled some that are
one that will be heard next
based on the
the
easy pass system
but
i mean there are definitely a lot of
considerations to to
examine and we look forward to bringing
data to the table and working with the
commission to come up with a solution
thank you
thank you uh for your testimonies are
are there any questions for solar
yes uh representative faulkner thank you
i don't know if you have this
information but uh
you indicated 4 000 electrical vehicles
electric
vehicles that seems
like a low share of the the nation's
total are we behind the behind the curve
on this or yes
new hampshire is the only state in the
northeast that has not adopted an
electric vehicle mandate
all of the other i think there's
14 northeast states
that have adopted the california
vehicle standards which require
that auto manufacturers offer for sale a
minimum percentage
of their total vehicles as evs
and that does not exist in new hampshire
so actually new hampshire dealerships
get fewer evs placed on their lots to
sell because the manufacturers don't get
the credits that they need in the other
states
i bought an ev i actually had to buy my
eev out of new jersey
so i couldn't get it out of new
hampshire
um
so yes
we have fewer and i and i think that
we're more in the you know six to seven
thousand range right now but again we
will hopefully have some updated data
in time for this study commission
thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none thank you so much for
appearing again i hold my hand the last
card i don't see anyone else moving
marie mullen
representing transportation in support
of the bill
please come forward good morning and
welcome
hi good morning
for the record marie mullen director of
finance for new hampshire d.o.t and here
to just support
the bill
we
you know have long advocated that the
fuel efficiency for all vehicles
has been eroding over time and will
continue to and as major
representative major has indicated i
think it's going to be accelerating very
quickly now with the adoption of
electric vehicles and all the
private businesses putting into this
this industry so we would support this
bill in looking at
you know alternative ways of looking at
this and
i'll
answer any questions that anyone may
seeing none thank you thank you
is there anyone that spoke wish to speak
seeing none i will call
the next hearing for house bill
for the members of the committee
assuming that i have 12 members back
here
at the conclusion of the hearing on 1656
i intend to exec
um
house bill 1038
which was the naming bill for a bridge
in londonderry you all should have
received the letter from the town of
londonderry and support i don't think
we'll have any problems executing that
bill
and i'd like to get it done so that we
can keep up with our work
but i do need 12 members here
are any of the sponsors of house bill
here
the time being 10 30 i will call the
public hearing on house bill 1656
and act establishing a road usage
registration fee and make an
appropriation therefore
to order
and i will recognize representative
peterson if you could go
who will introduce the bill on behalf of
i am representative michael peterson
from hillsboro 32 also known as nashua
ward 5.
the sponsor of hb 1656 is representative
peter samsich from portsmouth
he is not here today but he would like
for me to do a brief introduction of his
bill and when he comes before this
committee in person
uh he will
discuss it in
more complete terms
um
generating revenues for the roadways and
bridges
and mr samsich or representative samsich
thinks it will
dovetail along with hb 1040
collecting revenues based on the weight
of a vehicle in the annual miles driven
and representative sausage will go into
this in more detail
at a later date
thank you very much for your time
thank you for introducing it
for the members of the public who are
here to testify
um
here is my intent with this bill seeing
as how
um
i will hear testimony both for and
against the bill from members of the
public departments or whoever is here
and then i will recess and reopen the
public hearing next week
um it will be in the house calendar for
anybody who wants to to
either be here or follow it online
but as a courtesy to to the prime
sponsor i'm going to do that
but we will proceed today
um i have two pink cards anybody who
wishes to testify
um in support or opposition to
the bill
as written
i would appreciate the
pink card
the blue sheet is over there if you just
want to register your
approval or disapproval of the bill
first person
i'd like to speak is
jason stock
and representing the new hampshire
good morning
for the record i'm jason stock i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
timberland owners association and our
association represents certainly land
owners but we also represent people that
work in the forest and truck drive
trucks that carry forest products from
the woods to the sawmills and
in other destinations around the state
and i've
come today i'll be very brief to to just
express our our opposition to this bill
not only is there a cost factor but we
feel that
kind of allocating funds to you know you
have a a capital budget process
and what we don't
what we
fear is that we start creating
situations where i have a project or a
type of project and i want to have it
appropriated you know appropriate a
chunk of money for that
we feel that that would hamstring the
work of this committee down the road
when you look at the state's capital
needs on a holistic basis
and say all right what is really the
needs of the state when it comes to
infrastructure if it's noise abatement
if it's a bridge if it's
whatever we would hate to see that
effort hamstrung and so for the two
reasons one is the
increased cost
when i tried to calculate the cost using
the proposed formula the cost increase
i'm not quite sure i got the math right
i was never a really good math student
but it was significant
on a per truck basis so if you have a
fleet of trucks it would be significant
but secondarily there's kind of a
process issue and a process concern and
so with that i'll conclude my testimony
and be happy to try to answer any
questions
questions from the committee
gary abbott
associated general contractors in
thank you committee chairman for the
record my name is gary abbott i'm the
executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
i come today to you in opposition of the
bill
and i'm probably one who likes to
increase funding for the highways and
i like to support those bills that help
us build our roads but i think this bill
has
a couple of either premises or theories
used that are not quite correct
first of all the d.o.t
and our highways are built to a certain
standard to adequately
adequately hold the weight of trucks as
well as cars
they're built to a certain standard
to meet those legal limit weights
the other thing that's not really
included in here and i can go all the
way back to
i think it was the early 90s
when we demonstrated trucks
and their impact
braking distances back when we did
certified weights i know most of you
were not around back then
but we talked about the size of tires on
trucks compared to automobiles
their actual pressure impact is
different and it eases the weight across
the highway
so
we used as an example
a person with a small footprint with a
lot of weight actually has more impact
than a truck with all of those wheels
and all of that spread out weight
distribution that's why we have
certified weights and i'm kind of going
into something that's not really in the
bill but you have to understand
this bill kind of attacks by weight of a
vehicle on a road
it takes registration and redistributes
how those funds are collected
it lowers
the rates for automobiles
and it raises those for trucks
and i had a person in our office that
has a fleet of trucks and said this is
going to cost me about 300 percent more
for each truck
what i want to raise to you is that you
know how important trucking is today
after covid of two years and how we get
all our products and we're talking about
need for truck drivers and everything
else
so to put this financial burden doesn't
really put it completely on whatever
company it puts it back on you for the
cost of goods
so keep in mind that this uh shifting
then the bill has things that
we've talked about through noah majors
bill and others
how to keep track of how many miles
someone travels
nobody's figured that out yet it's in
this bill
we don't know how you would do that the
formula is so complicated
jason at least took a shot at it i
didn't take a shot at it because i could
not figure out
if my truck was in this category and
then there's a multiplying factor based
on miles
it just is very very complicated
it doesn't seem to really address some
of the other i actually don't like road
usage fee as a title on this bill
because it's more of the old days
if dick flynn the department of safety
said
we need a registration fee increase he
would come in with a form and say okay
five percent more we've looked at all
the surrounding states and we should
charge more and he'd come in with a
chart and yep truckers would go up five
percent more cars would go up five
percent more
that's how registrations fees work in
order to have enough funding for both
the department of safety and go into the
highway fund
this bill
when you look at the fiscal note has no
clue as to how much this brings in or
doesn't bring in
it's undetermined
it definitely has costs of trying to
figure out how to put in this
complicated formula
so
it was very hard for us because we don't
we don't know really what this does
except make everything much more
complicated it's not similar to the
other road usage
bills that you just heard
regarding trying to make sure vehicles
at least all pay the same way
the other thing that
you should understand trucks already pay
a lot more
trucks get six to 10 miles to the gallon
compared to motor vehicles i get 20 plus
there are already two times when you
start to do the gas tax and the others
and then you look at commercial vehicles
do travel a lot more than the average
citizen because they're out there every
day making money for the companies that
operate them
so trucks already pay a lot of money
when it comes to using our highways and
they pay
probably some trucking companies would
say they pay more than their fair share
if they were here today but i just want
to highlight all of that because as we
look at it
it just doesn't make a lot of sense to
do this complicated formula unless
you're looking at
carbon tax or some other i haven't
figured out
why we would be doing this
because we don't really know the money
we're not saying we need the money at
the moment so with that i would hope
this committee would really look at this
bill
just try to figure it out if you did own
an 80 000 truck how much you would pay
and i would hope the committee would uh
itl this legislation uh and i would end
my testimony and answer any questions
you may have
thank you mr abbott questions from
members of the committee
saying none i do have one
i'm not sure if you have an answer
but given the fact that
you said you're already paying a lot
more in registration and others
are any of your members registering
their trucks
in a neighboring state
because it's cheaper to register them in
a different state but can still work
i guess what i can tell you is
i'm aware that registering trailers is
much less expensive in other states and
would love to have the department and
safety others address that issue
and it's very easy in new england we're
a small state for companies to have
branch offices in other states to do
that it's not really usually the truck
it's usually the trailer
and there is a big disparity that we
charge a lot more in new hampshire than
other states
but that's
i'm aware of that particular issue but
if you legally
have a branch in another state you could
have those trucks or trailers registered
in those states
thank you
any further questions
i have no further paint cards
is there anybody who
has not testified on house bill
1656 who wishes to do so
please indicate at that now
is there anybody who has spoken once who
wishes to speak again
see none
i will recess
house bill the public hearing on house
to january 19th
to january 27th
at 9 30 in the morning um
to hear from the sponsor and anybody
else who
um
returns at that point to testify with
the committee being here
i would like to open
the executive session on house bill 30
naming the bridge
in londonderry in honor of robert j
prowse
we did not take this bill up at our last
executive session because we were
waiting on
confirmation from the town of
londonderry that they were not opposed
to
the naming of this bridge
we have all received a letter
from the town of londonderry saying they
are in support of that
so we will take it up now
and
mr chairman i move out to pass
on bill
h.b 1038
representative edgar moves um
ought to pass on house bill 1038
seconds the bill
um is there any discussion
representative
query
yeah this is just more of a question um
just that came to me over the last week
um the other day we heard uh or we heard
that the
name of a bridge stays with the bridge
and that this bridge is moving to keene
as
and i just wanted to know is it moving
as a footbridge or is it as a regular
bridge because i just want to make sure
that we're not like going to have two
bridges in different parts of the state
name
and then possibly mess up like google
maps and all those other
take take a shot at it barry
thank you the this bridge is going on in
a bike path it's a part of a
rail trail it's owned by the state
and it crosses over route 101
that
the old railroad bridge was taken down a
number of years ago so this would
replace that and would allow the rail
trail to be continued so it's not on the
that's satisfied
um
see no
further discu representative thompson
uh
mr chairman i just wanted to acknowledge
the
part of the testimony that we got the
other day that this gentleman was an
innovator in the bridge business
he um
accomplished things that other people
weren't able to and
improved the entire bridge system in
america as a result of that
i just think he deserves an
acknowledgement for the record
thank you
any further discussion
are you ready for the question
the motion is ought to pass on house
bill 1038 the clerk will call the roll
representative samurai aye
representative phadolfy hi
representative blasic
aye
representative thompson
representative boyd
boyd votes eye
representative clutier
yes representative edgar aye
representative evil
aye
clerk votes yes representative abbott
yes
representative
representative newman
yes
representative eaton
representative peterson
yes
and mr chairman
the vote being 17-0
consent calendar
any objections
it will go on the consent calendar thank
and no i tested negative uh
just so everybody knows um
and
the committee is in recess until
um 11
30 for house bill 1585
relative to removing the ramp tolls at
thank you very much go get a cup of
chairman i do have cough drops over here
anybody who is here to testify and
support or against house bill 1585
i would appreciate a pink card so i know
who to call
and uh if you're here
just in support or opposition the blue
sheet up there if you could sign that
and
um
indicate whether you're in favor or
opposed to the bill on the
wait
one minute see if my vice chair comes
back
i would like to open the public hearing
on house bill 1585 an act relative to
removing the ramp tolls at exit 11 in
hooksett and call on the prime sponsor
representative walsh who represents the
town of hooksett
there we go
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
for the record my name is tom walsh i'm
a representative from the town of
hooksett
and i'm here to introduce house bill
1585.
um
you probably don't often hear this but
i've been struggling on a direction on
how to present this to you all
so i'm going freelance off the cuff
i'll start by saying
i don't know if you're familiar with
exit 11 on route 93.
uh it's the toll booth um and it's
undeveloped been like that for a long
time with the exception of a of a brief
period there was an auctioneer there
that created a pad site
there is currently no infrastructure
there which the town is actually working
on we've adopted a tiff for water sewer
but all the roads in the area
hackett hill road is the main one
connects route 3a to the total
interchange
and
it goes beyond the interchange up to the
state shed with with offices and that's
all under the jurisdiction of the d.o.t
um
i looked at the direction again i just
wanted to shine some light on the issue
at exit 11 because it is prime for
development except for its its issues
and i didn't know how else to do it
um
i started with looking at the at the
tolls uh because of a sentiment that's
in town has been in town long before i
was a representative
but we've been
looking at our unique turnpike system
which is unlike most that's limited
access there's still plenty of ways to
get around tolls
and so the people in the
vicinities in my opinion and a lot of
people's opinions disproportionately pay
the tolls just for timing's sake for
their commutes
it's been almost 50 years i believe
since that toll's been there and
basically the only thing that we have to
show for it in the town is
the most dangerous intersection in the
town of hooksett
i'm also the chair of the hooksett
planning board we do see the hooks of
crash data every year
town wide and it's continually at the
top of the list for incidents
in all fairness i've been explaining to
my constituents over the years that
there's a 10-year plan
this has been on it for many years
unfortunately
it our fair share or our portion of the
contribution to the improvements at
hackett hill and 3a have failed on the
warrant because in my opinion some of
the sentiment people wondering
you know all these years we've been
paying tolls and what do we have to show
for it just
they don't think they should have to
raise taxes
uh on top of the tolls they're paying
anyway i've been still doing my due
diligence to
you know remind them how it works i it's
still on the 10-year plan i appreciate
that
um
the reason
the other reason i went this way is when
i received a
email from a 15 year old who's currently
going through driver's ed who is scared
for her life at the same intersection so
i felt i needed to do something
something some way to shine some light
on this
so that was the angle i took
for conceiving the bill
but now let me move into the the issues
with exit 11 and it's my opinion that
this would be prime it is prime for
development
uh we have a developer that's looking at
it now to introduce a 500 000 square
foot distribution facility he's got the
room for another 250 000 and that
doesn't even include the east side of
the
um of the highway
so they have done their own traffic
report this is it
uh the department of transportation i
believe did a peer review on it and
agreed
the the
road structure right there the road
system around that which is again all
controlled by dot
if you look at a glass of water in terms
of the traffic
it's not just full it's overflowing so
until we get a solution or some help
with making some needed upgrades to that
road system that's going to be an
undeveloped piece of property for a long
long time
the developers
and explain that situation there's no
way that we can actually approve any
more development over there until
something happens
their claim to me was that the dot was
actually not very cooperative with them
so they suggested if we give them a
conditional approval
maybe they'll get some more
some more feedback
we did
but i haven't heard anything in months
now from the developer to see that's
anything anything's changed so again i'm
not making any accusations i really just
for the committee wanted to explain
what's going on in hooksett and why that
that area is not developed
the people in town don't think it's
all their responsibility
and the developers of course are saying
it's not there nor do they have the
money to
to upgrade all the roads to handle any
development there it would be nice to
see not just for the people of town but
it would be a regional economic benefit
as well
so again
i'll be honest with you my expectations
are realistic when i put this bill in
but i didn't know how else to shine some
light on the whole situation again i do
appreciate the fact that hackett hill 3a
is still on the 10-year plan
it's in for 26. it's not going to do any
development any good on the immediate
in the immediate future but nonetheless
it's there
and
again i'm just trying to make this a
conversation that's all i have thank you
mr chair
um thank you for testifying uh questions
from members of the committee
representative jack
thank you mr chairman uh
and thank you the other chairman
i missed where the high accident
location is and i want to make sure i
all right one off
hackett hill road and 3a
and if you'd like i can reach out to the
hooksett pd and get you
several years back if you like
no thank you that's fine i just want to
make sure it's in a minute okay
so the toll you're asking for is if you
go up hack at hill road and take a right
that toll you want removed
and what's that going to do
[Music]
to
reduce that amount of traffic
i mean it it would seem like the toll
and i'm not in favor of the toll but
if uh it would seem like that
hole slows down some of that
issue
because they've got to pull through the
toll pull out to hackett hill take a
left
go down and and i've experienced that
i'm i'm just curious uh
why that
is preventing development is hack is
that hackett hill
access the only you're talking about the
plaza
if i can there's actually two sides
on both sides of the highway is open for
development the palazzi property is
available right now also
and the west side of the um
of the highway which it's a big bowl
actually the pad sites already been
installed
were created
but everybody's at a standstill until we
can get some answers on what the design
needs to look like on hacker hill road
to relieve all that pressure the reason
i brought up the tall angle was just out
of i'll be honest with you frustration
because i couldn't see anything going
and the sentiment of a lot of people in
town that say why are we after just in
my opinion because of the way you can
sneak around that toll all you want you
can go a couple of miles to exit 10 you
can go a couple of miles to exit 12. use
the same system and not pay
the people in town have been looking and
saying we do pay for this why do we have
to raise our taxes on the warren article
to get any improvements over there
that's why i took this angle i'm not
necessarily still looking at it i would
be more than happy to leave the tolls
there if we could get some legitimate
cooperation
and come to some solutions in a timely
fashion
to get this resolved and and and allowed
up
i thought i did
um hackett hill on the other end
on the southern end
does that access that well it's a large
loop it goes from the hookset
side by the tollbooth and it loops over
the hill back into the manchester side
back to 3a yeah it's a big loop
so that couldn't be used as an access
follow-up
any further questions
um
hopefully you as the
both the representative and and on the
planning commission
have tried to explain to the residents
of hooksett that the toll pace for the
turnpike and not for the rest of the
highways within the town
and that the turnpike runs up the
interstate and one and what you're
paying for is to use that section and
not 3a or or any of the rest of it
i have but i believe the turnpike would
still be responsible for the interchange
at hackett hill from the booth i'm not
that's that's what i believe i may not
be correct
any further questions see none thank you
i'd like to call
john cochran from new hampshire d.o.t
good morning thank you chairman graham
and the rest of the committee
the d.o.t is in opposition the bill
so first get started the turnpike
enterprise fund is a self-maintaining
fund through the collection of totals
this fund
pays for all the turnpike
operation and maintenance bond payments
campus program and r r
and there is no money supported through
the highway fund
over the past several years legislative
bills and government council approvals
have removed exit 11 and 12 toll plazas
which equated to approximately one point
four million pre-covered
post-covet is around seven hundred
thousand dollars in revenue
um with these removable toll plans the
department expresses concerns because
the erosion of the turnpike revenue
which is funded the entire turnpike
system
that we have the removal of these toll
plazas and we without any offsetting or
mitigating revenue enhancements
and we still have to maintain the whole
turnpike system
most recently exit 10
was removed in
1231.
that
loss of revenue is approximately
300k um there has been signage erected
there for the zero toll and we're
diverting people through lane one
and then this summer we'll be removing
that plaza for approximately another 800
000k
even 1 dollars sorry
um similar to exit 12 and 11 toll plaza
uh exit tens will not the removal this
summer will not include the building the
tunnel
um
reducing the ramp with to a single rank
rampling
that will be taken care of in the
nashville merrimack bedford project
that's coming up through and widening
the fv everett
this additional work will probably add
four million dollars to those projects
for the removal of the tunnel
as you all know covet has impacted our
revenue tremendously
based on our recent traffic and revenue
study in 2021
compared to the previous study in 2019
for our bond
refinancing
from fiscal year 20 to 30 we're losing
turnpikes
truthfully does not need another toll
plaza remove the loss in revenue and
hooksett ramp will range from 1.7 to 1.8
million dollars that revenue we will
lose there's also a possibility of
diversion from hooksett mainline because
there'll be a free
free access
we our traffic revenue consultant has
done a study on that
and they estimate the diversion will
cost us another 1.3 to 1.4 million a
year
this again in a 10-year period
represents another loss of 31 million
dollars for the turnpike system
in addition to the diversion of
the hooksett main line toll
we foresee that route 3a and hacking
hill road
congestion will be even worse than it is
now
as described before me that intersection
is very congested at peak periods
and by removing the hooksett ramp toll
it'll probably increase that
intersection to worse
um delays and
impacts to it
um the the loss in revenue impacts our
total operations which is mentioned
which includes our personnel and
staffing
and benefits costs our contract vendors
our materials
at this time of year salt that's all
part of that the equipment for our plow
trucks and
vehicles
and also
impacts the renewal replacement program
which is where we take care of all
resurfacing our bridge rehabs bridge
painting
and bond payments in the capital capital
program
as all of you know the decrease in
revenue has impact our capital program
as mentioned through a 10-year plan
hearings four of our major projects have
been
the department has worked hard over the
last decade to institute a sound finish
fiscal management even with the revenue
impacts due to covet
the removal of merrimack plazas we
continue to strive
and reduce our operation expense execute
our
r r program to keep the infrastructure
in good working order
and carry on with a capital program to
help reduce congestion
and safety
in 2019 when we went for refinancing of
our bonds
our
our rating was very it was excellent
the department again is going to
refinancing of our bonds we're working
on that where the goal is for may
and during our recent financial advisory
meeting they spoke to us about the
removal of exit 10 we were able to
address that but then they also heard
about xl possibility xl
xl11 hooksett ramp being removed that
raised serious concerns with them
and questions about the removal of that
due to the revenue
loss with that what that can help hurt
us is in our bond ratings and then also
when we're going to purchase bonds it
could be at a higher payment
and that concludes
my presentation
thank you
um before i open it up to questions from
members of the committee i do have one
um the previous speaker talked about
his understanding of how far out the
turnpike was responsible for
can you try to clarify that from members
of the committee does it end at the end
of the off ramp or does it extend
further out
we maintain all the way down the heck
hill road till 3a roots for new
hampshire through 3a we do not maintain
or responsible for new hampshire through
a 3a and then we go up packet hill road
to just beyond the bridge that goes over
the
interstate bridge it goes over 93.
that's the responsibility of the
thank you
representative
query thank you um
so two questions one would be somewhat
of a follow-up on uh chairman graham's
question
does that include um for maintenance of
that hackett hill road area does that
include
creating
traffic patterns and all that kind of
issues whether that be stop signs yield
signs
new hampshire 3a is maintained by um
district five of the highway fund we
would work with them but they're mainly
in control that intersection i guess i
meant uh further up on
within the the hackett hill area yes
from 3a up to where i mentioned where
our responsibility ends near the bridge
which is near our office
and then a second
thank you um
so my other question would be is
are there any
regulations about how far a tollbooth
plaza has to be away from any kind of
uh like stoplight because i'm just
looking at the map here of that specific
area
and it seems like there'd only be about
25 yards or so
from the toll plaza to where a stop
light could be placed is there any
regulations about that so that it
during the like the intersection re
design they will look at that but
there's no like regulations for that
okay thank you
further questions representative boyd
thank you mr chairman mr corker and
thank you for your testimony
um alluding to my colleagues testimony
regarding
the town of hooks that has d.o.t ever
had any ex parte conversation
with either the landowners that have
bought the exit eleven interchange of
the town of hooksett regarding those
development opportunities that my
yes that's part of um we call it a
uh driveway review
um the d.o.t isn't part of that and
right now it's in the
the part of the review is in the traffic
study part of it and that goes through
our bureau of
traffic and we work with them
follow up
thank you
um
so west river road
also known as 3a
is managed by
not the d.o.t but
it's d.o.t but a different division yes
it's these d.o.t highways versus d.o.t
turnpikes
okay
has there ever been any contemplation
because i i share my colleagues concern
because it is
for the lack of a better word it is
treacherous trying to negotiate a
left-hand turn coming out of that exit
um to head northbound on 3a has there
ever been any conversations
with the town both in both departments
regarding widening that interchange
traffic calming anything to that extent
that would mitigate
some of the concerns that my colleague
alluded to
all right for the record uh i'm william
cassie assistant commissioner i figured
i'd help john with this answer because i
i've been involved with this for a
little bit longer um representative
walsh i think alluded to it there had
been a
it originated from some prior
development uh
initiatives that had happened that never
took place there but associated with
those prior developments that didn't go
forward we had committed to improvements
at that intersection in conjunction with
the town
through what used to be known as the
state aid highway program and that was
state funds that were matched by
one-third
town funds
um to address that that intersection so
we we had worked through that and i i
forget the exact details but it must
have been a couple of couple of years
ago that
we had worked it up to taking it to bid
the bids came in um
higher higher than our estimates and and
i believe he associated that when it
went back to the town for the additional
um
revenue it wasn't supported through a
warrant article
and the project never had had moved
forward so
with that at this update of the 10-year
plan and
he had alluded to that as well to one of
um i think council of gatsas's
priorities as well was to
uh make sure that that was included in
the in the in the 10-year plan
uh
i
i don't believe it has any town funds
now that we're going to take it on we're
going to put it maybe there are some
residual state aid highway funds i'll
have to check but essentially it's been
put in the federal program to to to do
that intersection
uh it is programmed in in he said 2026 i
believe that's right so
we also committed with that i know part
of the concerns were also at the um a
little bit further north at the main
street intersection and 3a so both of
those intersections we're going to look
at as one 10-year plan project uh to uh
to bring forward uh through the ten-year
plan
maybe a long answer but i think that's
somewhat of the history and now defaulty
you're welcome and
the issue before us is the removal of
tolls not the rest of the 10-year
project in hooksett
um just keep that in mind when we're
contemplating what to do with this bill
having said that are there any other
questions
okay sorry okay thank you
something you said earlier and i just
wanted to be clear it sort of jumped out
at me you said the
we are losing 118 million dollars is
that just the turnpike system and for
how long or the entire
budget
that is just a turn fight system and
it's due to covet because of reduced
traffic and that is from fiscal year 20
to fiscal year 30. and that's based on
our previous estimate prior to covit our
traffic and revenue study into our
revised one after covet okay follow up
okay everybody hear me
okay so what
time period is that loss again i just
want to be clear i was a little confused
sorry fiscal year 20 which started in uh
july
1st of 2019 and then it goes to fiscal
year
30 which ends in june 30th
uh
2030.
so this is i mean it's a 10-year period
yeah like approximately 10 years about
11 years total you estimate okay thank
you thank you mr chairman
any further questions
seeing none
has anybody
who has
not testified on house bill
wish to testify anybody who's testified
once on
house bill 1585 wished to speak a second
time saying none the public hearing
on house bill 1585
is closed
and the committee has until 1 15
when we'll begin our next hearing thank
i'm about to open the hearing on house
bill 1675.
if you are speaking
in favor or opposed to the bill i would
like to see a
pink card so i know who to call on
if you don't wish to speak but just wish
to
sign in on the blue sheet and indicate
whether or not you're supportive or
opposed to the bill i would appreciate
that as well
and i will now open the public hearing
on house bill 1675
an act establishing a surcharge
collected through easy pass for electric
vehicles as an alternative road toll and
call on the prime sponsor uh
representative thompson representative
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
uh house bill 1675a
fna
it's an amendment to rsa 260 a bill that
would attach an additional 50 cent fee
to the road toll charged on any toll
booth in new hampshire with respect to
an electric vehicle
the state of new hampshire currently has
2 800 electric vehicles are registered
in the state according to the dmv
most of which are located in the
southern part of the state
the state of massachusetts has twenty
one thousand ten
in the state of maine has nineteen
thousand uh nineteen hundred and twenty
it's assumed for the purpose of this
bill that many or most of these vehicles
will pass through
the new hampshire tolls a number of
times a week each of the toll plazas in
in hooksett and hampton have multiple
charging stations that will attract ev
users
in both directions in and out of the
state with the theory that most electric
vehicles have relatively limited travel
distance
as opposed to a gasoline-powered vehicle
each electric vehicle
can carry 136
can travel 136 miles for the 32 miles
that a gas powered vehicle can go on one
gallon of gas
my source for this is the epa
given the current gas tax in new
hampshire 24 cents a gallon a gas
vehicle will cost you a dollar two to go
136 miles and the bill asks for the
owners of electric vehicles to pay only
50 cents for the same mileage although
it seems that electric vehicle owners
get a substantial discount over a gas
vehicle they deserve it as they will
emit no carbon footprint although they
need to pay something for new
hampshire's roads and bridges and
gas-powered owners need an incentive as
well to purchase electric vehicles
both gm and chrysler have announced that
they will no longer produce
internal combustion engines after 2035.
this bill is a simple short-term
solution to a long-term problem i hope
that the legislature will come up with a
permanent long-term solution within the
next couple of years in this bill can
sunset
you can use these comparisons assuming
50 cent 50 percent of the vehicles
use use is off turnpike
and if someone uses their electric
vehicle twelve thousand miles a year on
the road system it'll cost them roughly
six hundred and sixty six dollars
based on 136 mile per toll use
if someone uses their gas vehicle 12 000
miles a year in the road system with 50
percent off turnpike it will cost them
1440.
based on 136 miles per use
i have a couple of comments that have
resisted this formula
opposed to the registration to uh
and supported original or
additional registration fees or a fee by
weight of the vehicle i don't believe
either of these ideas will work for the
registration fee
to work one would have to know how many
miles a year a vehicle travels
in order to calculate the gas tax with
relation to the registration fee i
believe that's undeterminable
for the weight system to work the value
of a pound
to the cost of the gas tax on each
individual combined with a calculation
of how a pound of weight would affect
the damage to the road system i believe
is also indeterminable
that's my testimony mr chairman if
anyone has any questions i'll do the
best i can to answer them
questions from members of the committee
representative faulkner
well my understanding is that the
toll tags can be used on multiple
vehicles and some people have one tag
that can be shared by several vehicles
as
you thought of a way that
could restrict the use of a tag to
so that it okay
thank you
further questions um one question and
you may want to defer to the department
when they testify
out of state vehicles that are ev how
would
our toll collectors with ezpass know
i was told that the
the easy pass system has that
information in their databases and it is
accessible
but there would be a fee to the state
and the fee was unknown based on
thank you further questions from members
i'd like to call kelly buchanan and
clean energy new hampshire back to
thank you mr chair members of the
committee good to see you again today my
name is kelly buchanan director of
legislative and regulatory affairs for
clean energy new hampshire
and i will keep my testimony very brief
this morning in light of what i shared
with you this morning in regards to
house bill 1040.
but while we don't disagree that eb
should certainly pay their fair share or
their equitable share of maintaining our
roads and bridges we feel this bill is a
little
a little early in the process it would
be more appropriate to quickly determine
a consensus solution to some sort of an
alternative
to the road toll in that study
commission that was proposed in house
bill 1040.
so i would be happy to take any of your
questions
um thank you
questions from members of the committee
i'm john corcoran from new hampshire
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee
the d.o.t has no position on this bill
although we do have some operational
concerns with it
presently our account our easy pass
account hunters are not required to tell
us if their vehicle is electric
also this bill is being
tied to a tag a transponder
several householders households might
not only have one transponder and they
move between cars
so that means
a non-electric vehicle would be charged
that surcharge
we also foresee customers forgetting to
update their accounts when they get rid
of their electric vehicle and then
there'll be additional
one reimbursement for the excess charge
we also believe the bill isn't fair to
new hampshire residents because majority
of them are
easy pass
customers new hampshire easy pass
customers will only be getting a charge
not an easy pass
non-new hampshire easy pass customers
will not be getting a charge
also the cash customers on a turnpike
don't get
charged the electric
vehicles also are not being charged
outside the turnpike in other state
highway systems
the cost of the
the bill was indeterminal because we are
unsure of how many electric vehicle
users have accounts in the ezpass system
we also know there will be additional
costs but there was undeterminable if
the bill is passed changes to our easy
pass system
also the website application we'd also
have to create a file of transferring
the
turnpike funds
into the highway fund
and there will also be a future
problem of administrator cost of dealing
with customers not updating their
accounts and also auditing the fund
transfer with the turnpike funds to the
highway fund
if you have any questions
thank you
representative jack
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for coming in uh i believe this is the
first case that we've had where we've
considered having part of toll
collections go somewhere other than the
turnpike fund is that
um
i can't directly answer i believe it
would
create an issue because it's on the
turnpike system but with the law intact
in maine not i can't totally agree with
that
first representative boyd
thank you mr chairman
how
easy
would it be
to code a transponder
by license plate to the applicable
vehicle being driven concerning that
tesla to my knowledge is the only pure
that would be
extremely hard
the vendor who sells the transponders
they do not do that now
it would require that vendor to make a
complete change in the transponders
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you further questions from members
i have no other pink cards is anybody
who has not spoken
on house bill 1675 wish to speak
anybody who has spoken once wished to
speak a second time
saying none i will close the public
hearing on house bill 1675.
and once again i must judge the time
and we do not have a further
another hearing until
1 45
which is
hb 2022 relative to the 10-year
transportation plan
for the committee
there are copies of the plan on the box
and
if we run out i'm sure we can find
others but please
they're for the committee's youth at
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i'm
representative john graham
i represent hillsborough district 7
which is the town of bedford
um
as a courtesy to the governor i i am
introducing house
house bill 2022 which is the 10-year
transportation plan
i believe all of you got the governor's
letter where he transmitted
the policy that came out electronically
if not
talk to me later and i'll make sure you
get a copy
he does talk about the process a little
bit
and the next speaker up will be the
department of transportation who will go
over
a follow-on to what we heard last week
about the process but exactly what is in
this plan how how it was changed and how
additional federal money made late
changes to the plan
and with that i will say that i am going
to be chairing the remainder of the
hearings on house bill 2022 and i will
um thank you
next
led by commissioners in the department
will
present
their briefing on house bill 2022 and
specifically on the 10-year
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee and thank you for this
opportunity to present
on the content of the 10-year plan
in
introducing the bill
representative graham
shared that the passage of the iija the
infrastructure investment and jobs act
occurred
in the final
weeks of the gasset phase of the 10-year
plan and so
in our first presentation last week we
tried to
share with the committee information on
the different types of funding available
for transportation investment as well as
the current condition
at the request of the committee today
we're going to focus more on the content
of the 10-year plan and the strategies
that were supported by the executive
council when they met as gasset as we
developed first the draft that we use
for the purposes of
receiving public testimony
and then the strategies that were
further
used to help
identify where the additional investment
provided by the federal bill should be
made so
with that i'm going to turn it over to
our director of project development pete
stamnis who once again will walk you
through the presentation that we've
prepared
thank you commissioner uh good afternoon
everyone again peter stamnis director of
project development for dot
we
handed out a few pieces of information
one was the the presentation that i'm
going to go through
second piece
was a project change table much of this
all this information is in the
presentation but with a separate
separate copy of it for you
there's also a
municipal bridge project acceleration
list that's also in the presentation and
we presented the provided a factbook
also
moving on to the presentation
outline on page two
federal funding summary
review the strategies
for
development of the draft initial draft
identify investments for the additional
funding that was included in the iija
as it was passed late in the game
um
we go through the those changes in the
change table
and then a few of the items that we
wanted to make sure that
were brought up
so page three federal funding review
we showed this chart in the last time we
were here
[Music]
and this is a breakdown of the
iija and all the funding categories
included
on the far left you see
included in the iija for highway
programs is 1.139 billion
bridge program
225 million dollars
ev charging program 17.3
million dollars
public transportation
and for airports
45.6 or total of 1.5
6 billion
dollars
the
uh column immediately to the right five
year prior appropriations this includes
the
the funding and the fast act that was um
for the for a previous five-year
plan
uh and and you look the bottom line
total there for transportation is one
million uh just a little over one
million dollars so if you subtract that
second column from the first column you
get the new
money in the um
represented here in the uh
the 10-year plan the draft 10-year plan
545 million dollars
in new money
the following uh column is what has been
included in the draft and the book that
you have in front of you right now one
point just under 1.5 billion dollars
there's a couple of categories on on the
public trans transportation and the
airport side
we we haven't had we don't have enough
information on those um
on those funds yet so they haven't have
not been included in
moving on to
page
so from a federal funding review so the
the chart in front of you um
represents um the orange
bars
by fiscal year are the investments
on the federal
side on the federal highway side
funding standpoint
that are included in the current
10-year plan 21 through 20 30 10-year
plan by fiscal year
the green
uh line um associated with those orange
bars is represents 183 million dollars
in apportionment so that's the portion
funds
that we use to constrain the 10-year
plan from the federal highway
category
of funding
the blue bars
in this chart represent the investments
included in the draft 10-year plan for
the 23-32
period
and similarly the black line represents
overall apportionment that's provided
[Music]
from 2023 through 2026 and then level
funded from there on out through the end
of 2032
so just a general comparison
um
for
the
overall program that's in the current
10-year plan shown by the orange bars
and the increase in funding on the
federal side shown in the blue
blue bars from an investment level
standpoint
there's some
summaries on the bottom there that
on the next slide
strategies this is overall strategies
that utilize to build the initial draft
we
funded the regional priority project so
there's 50 million dollars
allocated to the last two years of the
of the the draft 10-year plan and that's
distributed amongst the regional
planning commissions 25 million uh for
each year and those um that process that
we went through
um utilized that 50 million dollars to
fund new projects into the plan
another strategy was we wanted to focus
on maintenance and preservation of the
existing network of roads and bridges
we continue to invest in core system
programs
and build on
previous successes and by the
investments in these programs those
include pavement and bridge preservation
programs
our
rehab and reconstruction of redless
bridges and we wanted to accelerate the
overall removal of those and our target
would be to try to
remove
all existing redless bridges within a
seven six to seven year time period
instead of extending those out through
the entire 10-year plan so accelerate
them where we can
and we continue to invest in in overall
road roadside assets including culverts
guard rail pavement markings and signs
next bullet uh federal reauthorization
so we had at this point the iija hadn't
been approved and we were assuming uh
that there was going to be some
additional funds and these bullets
identify how we plan to utilize those
additional funds from a prioritization
standpoint
we wanted to accelerate existing 10-year
plan projects where possible
fully fund
scope constrained uh 10-year plan
projects that are currently in the plan
convert garvey bonded projects to
modify existing programs in uh by
adjusting funding to include
inflationary um uh adjustments overall
in the in the uh in the programs
and then we would consider new projects
in the outer years to improve safety and
capacity
this next
slide if if i could just ask one quick
question
it has nothing to do with with what
you're
talking but is this presentation
currently up on your website
it is not posted yet okay i was just
wondering for people who are trying to
watch us online if there was a way that
they could follow along but take notes
so moving on to the next slide um
strategies for
overall highway programs
so
some of the changes
that were included in the giraffe the
original draft in september we had an
increase in pavement investment by 168
million dollars and that's over the the
10-year period
increases in
bridge investment for the state assets
state-owned bridges of 169
million dollars and the breakdown for
those increases are shown in the bullets
below
we converted
projects funded with garvey funds and
that's a that's a federal um
bond program that uses future uh federal
uh obligational authority to pay debt
service we had 163 million dollars in in
garvey bonds that were funding a number
of projects
and uh net the debt service that was
included in the current 10-year plan on
those garvey bonds of 105 million the
increase uh to the plan was 58 million
i wanted to fully fund scope constrained
projects that added 54 million dollars
and if we go to the next slide
you'll see a
list of projects
that make up that 54 million so there
were a number of projects that we had
identified in the current 10-year plan
the scope of work in order to fit the
budget that we had
available to us
and by
having this
additional federal funding
available we were identifying these
projects and then adding funds to those
existing 10-year plan projects to get us
closer to if not at the original scope
of work what was intended
when the when the project came in to the
to the plan and i'm not going to go
through and um
list all of these but it gives you some
sense for
which projects and how much additional
funds we we included in the original
so
at this point in time
we had learned that the
had had passed
and this was a second piece of funding
so
if you go to page
page three in the presentation the
bridge program this 225 million dollars
in the original draft that 225 million
dollars was not included so these are
changes that we made
as a result of the passing of the iija
so we are allocating 15
of that 45 million dollars per year so
it's a five-year program 225 million
dollars 45 million dollars per year 15
of that to the municipal bridge program
6.7 million dollars
and the balance
of that 45 million dollars per year that
was coming in
we would allocate to existing bridge
projects and what that would do is that
would free up funds
that were allocated to those bridge
projects to use on other projects so
it's more flexible
overall
and the bullets here below that will
increase the mandated programs to align
with the increased apportionment it was
about 7.3 million dollars a year for
some of these programs highway safety
improvement
transportation alternatives programs
cmac rec trails etc
we funded administrative project changes
and we'll go through those in a few
slides
and also there were a number of
projects that had
scope or cost increases that we're aware
of and additional increases based on
input that we received
at the
so
additional strategy
on the next next slide slide nine
the electrical
electric vehicle um charging program so
the infrastructure program 17 million
dollars in in new funds
uh three and a half million dollars per
year for a five-year period we created
an ev program that's included in the
current 10-year
from a public transportation standpoint
there's 33 and a half million dollars in
new funds and the allocations across
individual fta programs are not uh
currently known we only know the
apportionments
however 15 million of the total of 33.5
million dollars are not included in the
draft and the and this is uh funding
that will get included as we learn more
similarly on the airports uh anticipate
45.6 million dollars in new funds um the
faa projects are not part of the surface
transportation bill and the new funds
are not included in this draft and uh
will be at a later date once we learn
i wanted to mention active
transportation we hear a lot about a lot
of comments about
active transportation throughout the
hearing process
we invest approximately in this draft
around 17 million dollars per year on
average uh for the 10-year uh period
and um
we were asked to provide more
transparency in how
those investments were being made for
this category so we created a new a new
category and and some of our funding
charts so that it would be called out
and and it would be clear how much
we expected to spend for this category
next slide slide 10.
so
and we had mentioned this last time we
were here we had
22 public hearings and we also held one
um all virtual uh hearing again to
gather
um input on the draft 10-year plan the
september version of the draft 10-year
plan
and that was a
pretty busy uh five or six weeks of uh
of uh hearings and and uh we collected a
lot of
a lot of testimony uh across uh uh
statewide
go to slide 11 um we also
created a
online survey
again to reach those who may not be able
to attend the hearings and to
try to get as much feedback on and
commentary on the draft 10-year plan as
possible
overall the conclusions of the survey
that the public's
support for the department's strategic
direction and priorities for
transportation investments was there we
saw that in the
slide 12
this shows um a graphics um so the
online survey is shown in blue on the
left and there were 760 online surveys
that were completed
and on the right
there were 456 hearing comments that we
received as part of the hearing process
each one the categories for both we
tried to capture um and and and
categorize the comments that we received
and these five
were some of those very
general uh categories that we wanted to
use
and what was clear is expanding travel
options
the commentary that we received both
online and in the hearing we received
most comments on expanding travel
options and
as you go to the right improve safety
maintaining the system reduce congestion
enhance system resiliency you'll see
that
from a prioritization standpoint
a higher priority of the or the the
number of comments that we received were
higher to the left
and
as you proceed to the categories to the
right
the the lesser amount of commentary
was
provided again strong advocacy for
expanding travel options and then
followed by improving safety maintaining
the system and reducing congestion
we also heard a lot about specific
project needs
um within each one of the hearings that
we did
hold
uh one one moment
would
you prefer that we hold the questions
representative query why don't we let
him get through and then we can go back
because it may get answered further on i
the next set of slides
go through
the
project change list and these are
changes that um
we're documenting um
following the initial draft in the
september 17th version of the initial
draft of the
transportation plan this is kind of our
change log um and there are various
categories of changes i'm not going to
go through each one on this list but
this is the this is the list that i
provided a separate handout for you it's
the same same information just in a in a
separate uh package
uh the first slide uh of the of the
change is slide 13 and that these are
administrative uh changes
and many of these projects here
um made it on to the administrative
change list they were for instance the
first one conway
40638 this is a project that was
originally uh currently funded in the in
in the 10-year plan in 2022
but it was delayed until 2023 so we
needed to make this administrative
change so that would show up in this uh
new draft so many of these are uh you'll
note that they're similar similar in
nature and that's why we call them the
administrative changes they're already
included in the plan we just wanted to
make sure that they were included in the
moving on to slide 14
additional administrative changes
these
nine project listings were
bridge state state-owned bridge projects
that we introduced
in the draft as
new new projects in the outer years
and uh in an effort to accelerate them
and try to remove the redless bridges
faster than we had originally envisioned
we accelerated these projects so they're
really they were already included in the
draft
we just moved them
a year or two
to remove them from the list sooner to
get the work done sooner there are nine
slide 15 scope and cost adjustments so
um
during the the you know the summer
months we um
made aware of um scope adjustments in in
existing projects and cost increases in
existing projects
and we wanted to make sure that we
captured those as part of the 10-year
plan process um and so uh for instance
um one of these the first one here
concord four one two one two
it's a uh
bridge rehabilitation project on on lown
road over the
over the
merrimack river and we were made aware
of a significant
cost increase driven by a scope
modification so in this case
there was a 14 million dollar increase
which brought the total project cost up
to 22 million dollars so each one of
these has a story i'm not going to go
through it at this point but
each one of these
we wanted to make sure that we
documented the change from the the uh
the initial draft of the of the 2023-32
plan that was presented at the hearings
now slide 16 some more scope and cost
adjustments
one of the ones that i will highlight
here
two thirds of the way down the list
walpole new hampshire rockingham vermont
four one seven two zero
this particular change we increased the
new hampshire participation from 50
percent
to 93 so this is the vilas bridge we
have been funding that project at 50
percent um
new hampshire and fifty percent other
um and and as part of the scope
adjustments we uh modified
that uh participation percentage to
align with
the state line split that we typically
93 percent new hampshire seven percent
vermont
and that was a nine million dollar
increase overall uh from a funding
overall the scope and cost adjustments
and in the previous slides are about 121
million dollars and that's summarized
slide 17
this identifies uh the the increase in
funds that we were utilizing here
between
between the the initial draft and and
the uh
the version that you have in front of
you
that are listed here
municipal bridge program and the ev
charging program so that's the new
funding that we
[Music]
included
overall 242 million dollar increase
again 225 million for the bridge uh
funds 17.3 million for the electric
vehicle
uh program
through the years of 23 through 27 and
again the details for those are
slide 18
there were also some new projects added
as part of the gasset
process and this identifies the list of
new projects that were added
i'll note
at the bottom of the list there hooksett
that's a new project that's
hackett hill road new hampshire 3a
intersection and main street
improvements
overall this was a project that
had was a
locally managed project that
was
bid out and was never uh awarded
um and so uh that we received some um
commentary and input from from uh
from hooksett at one of the hearings and
this was one of the projects that was
uh entered back into the in into the
plan
slide 19
accelerated municipal bridges so this is
a this is a list of 29 municipal bridge
projects
that were
funded in the current 10-year plan
21-30 plan using state bridge aid funds
and as part of that 15 percent uh of the
uh the new bridge funds that were
um brought into the plan we were able to
accelerate a num all of these bridges
here so the 29 of them that we
accelerated by a way of utilizing this
additional funding um that was approved
within the iija
again there's the whole list here but it
some of them were advanced one year some
of them
you know three years some of them four
years but
basically we we tried to accelerate as
many as we could
um
with the funds that were available
for only those bridges that were already
included in the plan so we plan to do a
new solicitation
uh for the balance of funding both in
the in the state aid bridge program and
also
if there's any additional funds
available
through the federal funding of this
program we will do a new solicitation
and bring those in in the next update of
moving on to slide 20.
[Music]
this this slide
we've been carrying through since the
initial gasset meeting that we had
in the summer
and we wanted to make sure that we had
identified these projects in in and
ultimately at this point in time where
they stand
within within the draft of the uh that
you have in front of you
so tilton 29753 calif hill road it is
included in the draft utilizing uh 3.25
million dollars in general funds
portsmouth kittery one five seven three
one
uh it's a port authority functional
replacement associated with sarah
mildred long bridge replacement overall
uh 32 million dollars in construction we
had applied for
a 14 million dollar uh grant
um federal grant which was unsuccessful
and we plan to fund that with uh
2022. so outside of this current draft
but we do plan to fund that 14
plus million dollars with federal funds
we have a exit sign renumbering project
on on the interstates statewide four
zero nine one five it was originally
included in the draft in in 2024
i-95 portsmouth sound wall project
um it's included in the draft and it was
originally funded with turnpike funds
and the construction phase
was accelerated and funded with federal
funds
10 million dollars
dover rochester somersworth 40599
spalding exit spaulding turnpike exit 10
study uh it was included in the draft
and the scope was expanded
and the funding was um uh
in 2024 so it was a little broader um
broader scope of work
and it was split funded um one million
with turnpike and one million federal
funds dixville colebrook 40518 balsams
golf links road not included in the
draft
hudson
42108 circumferential highway not
included in the
draft that concludes
ah thank you thank you for the
presentation and the update on how
things change from the time some of us
went to the gasset hearings to
what is in front of us
and where the the federal money went um
representative query you remember your
question
i uh luckily wrote it down um
uh
yeah i just wanted to go back to
uh page 12. um
and just wanted to get a quick
clarification on
it what
uh your definition of expand travel
option is and what the uh
the audience of the survey
was like like what was their prompt
in answering expanded travel options i
first
so
many times um there are comments that we
receive that um call this a highway plan
and this is a transportation plan
and it includes uh many uh modes of of
of travel
so more than just highway and bridge it
so expanded travel options also
moves towards um
investments in in paths and
and sidewalks so people getting getting
people out of cars
and uh utilizing um
pedestrian facilities and
rail trails and those
those types of uh
travel options so we hear a lot of uh
feedback and commentary um
on expanded travel options and we
that's why it's acknowledged here within
the survey results and also within the
with respect to what was the prompt when
they were completing the survey we
actually had a question where you could
take
these five elements
expanding travel options maintain the
system
as well as a couple of other ones and
rank them in importance and so we heard
a lot of
feedback that expanding travel options
follow-up
and just to follow up on that so is the
are the charts just um
their number one option or is it kind of
like
every like each one was valued at a
point or something
if it's helpful we could provide the
committee with the responses to all of
the survey questions and you'll see
how we
then use that information to inform the
decision making what we're showing this
slide is just one question there was a
thank you representative jack
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming uh i i'm gonna have two questions
uh early on before you said something
about redless bridges and six to seven
years and what i got from it was you
wanted to wipe out
the redless bridges did i did i
all um
so
all of the redless bridges that we are
aware of are um they're they're included
within this 10-year plan say for five
this i believe there's five that are not
included in this plan and generally
we are adding
um new projects new bridges to the plan
every two years through this update
process
in the latter two years of the plan
and
as part of this additional funding that
we received we included
funding
to a red less bridge program
um in the outer years of the plan
to a tune of about 120 million or so
and what that will allow us to do is to
when new bridges do come on
that they will be
we can we we have room in the plan
earlier than later in order to
accelerate their removal so we
i think we're estimating that each year
um we'll have somewhere between 12 and
14 um bridges come on to the red list
so presumably every two years we're
going to have another two dozen or so
that we're going to need to include in
the plan and what this my comment was
that we would try to remove those sooner
than later if we can adequately fund it
um and that the bridges won't stay on
the red list for as long as they had
been uh previously
great and if you would indulge me for a
second question
the 60 million that you haven't
allocated yet
uh that you say you don't have enough
information
is the timing on that that you're going
to get it done before the senate while
the senate has possession of it because
once we pass the 10-year plan you can't
add anything as i understand it
so it's still unclear when
usdot will make available the
apportionment tables
so for example on the public transit
side when we met last time we walked you
through the different types of
funding available whether it's money for
urban systems or for rural systems what
we're waiting for is the exact amount
each of those categories
and then we'll make the adjustments so
that might be during this phase or it
might be a couple of months out and be
during the senate phase
with the airports it's a little bit more
challenging because
aeronautics is not funded through
surface transportation so we know this
additional money is coming but i think
it will take a little bit longer for us
to get the information on what types of
projects
will be eligible and exactly how much
for the question further questions from
the committee
uh
thank you mr chair and thank you for
being here i just i don't know how much
detail
you have available at this point but i'm
wondering what what really is an ev
program you develop the
idea of where you're going to put them
do you are you thinking about putting
them on state loan land do you have to
release land how much is a station
i mean i
we're talking a lot about building out
our ev infrastructure and any detail i'd
appreciate
thank you
so the eevee
charging program is a new category of
funding
there's actually two opportunities and
what we have included in the 10-year
plan is the funds that were received by
formula
there's also going to be a discretionary
grant program so new hampshire could
apply
and compete to secure additional dollars
beyond the 17 million that we've
included
in the 10-year plan
at this point what we know is that we do
need to develop a plan on where we would
install these electric charging units
before we'll be able to access those
federal funds and we are waiting for
more guidance from usdot on how they're
going to administer that particular
program
and what the rules will be around
accessing those federal funds but we do
know that an element of that is
developed developing a plan to show
where we intend to install the units and
how we have
determined where they're most
appropriately cited
and we'll be working very closely
when it comes to ev charging
infrastructure you know we've been
working with our colleagues at the
department of environmental services
and talking with the utility companies
about the role that they'll play and so
while the funds are flowing through
usdot to the department of
transportation
we'll be of course partnering with the
other state agencies who
play a significant role when it comes to
so how long will it take to develop your
plan
it depends on when federal highway
releases the guidance because we want to
make sure that our plan is in compliance
so
we're
working very closely with usdot and with
federal highway specifically to
understand when the guidance documents
will be available
but you have to appreciate you know the
bill was only passed at the end of last
year there's a number of discretionary
programs as well as these new formula
programs so it will take some time for
all of the guidance documents to be
i'm
following on on that one so when you say
it's included in the 10-year plan i'm
not going to find anything in this book
that says ev charging or am i
where
programs
um it'll cev program
i'll tell you what page
uh later at some point you're gonna have
to point that out to at least me
representative thompson has a question i
believe i do
thank you for coming commissioner and
director
we had some discussion earlier today on
a bill that
was concerned with the hackett hill road
3a intersection
and i see that you've got that in your
new projects i wonder if you could
explain a little bit
so um the initial
scope of
work for the
municipally managed project was to
um
when they actually designed a roundabout
at 3a and hackett hill road
again it was designed it was advertised
for construction bids were received and
the town did not award because of the
price
increase
um we think it's a
this
you know the the
some of the issues
along 3a within that immediate area
we find this value in this project
and so this project would expand the
footprint a bit and also take a look at
the
signalized intersection to the north
of hackett hill road and we'd look to
engineer a solution
that would encompass both of those
intersections and improve overall
thank you very much
all right okay all right thank you
representative jack a question and i'd
like to on page seven of the slide
presentation funding to scope
constrained projects and specifically
dopt projects i'm looking at the project
in charleston along route 12 which
project number five four zero six six
seven
road restoration and
rehabilitation and i noticed you had it
listed for just over 14 million an
additional 5 million is any of that
money
because of a situation in that area now
that root part of route 12 was damaged
because of flooding
and i guess there was a contract awarded
by the governor and council
on that issue and i know by the way your
kathleen mulcay hampson has been keeping
us reps from our area informed i asked
her us to keep this committee brief does
any of that related to that fixing that
issue which is
supposed to be fixed by end of april
uh no sir
we just reviewed overall scope and and
sized it appropriately to fit the
footprint of the project so there was
additional funds that were necessary
okay so that has nothing to do with what
is going to fix that there are two
separate projects one is to repair the
damage and make sure that the road is
passable again and then this is a
project that was already moving forward
before the storm
hit
all right okay thank you so so it's
basically all this money is for the
long-term restoration of route 12.
correct all right okay thank you thank
you mr chairman
other questions i would remind the
committee that we have two full days or
at least a day if we don't need two full
days
of of work session
dealing with the entire program and the
department will be here for those
those meetings so as you go through not
just the slides but looking at the book
over the next week um
let's
look at that and and then ask the
specific question i'm not going to show
anybody off right now
but um
you know sometimes
it's better if you look and figure out
what was in the last one what's in this
one oh if you want copies the last one i
have a box of them on my desk
which
because the covert never got handed out
thank you mr chairman
and uh thank you for taking my question
uh it has to do on page 20.
uh the portsmouth kittery the 15 7 31
port authority uh
the functional replacement
you know because of the bridge work that
was done nearby and they had to you know
actually fix some of the area that
where it was
is the full 32 million for construction
um so originally we had hoped to secure
a discretionary grant to supplement what
was budgeted in the last 10-year plan
for this particular project
unfortunately we were unsuccessful in
securing that grant because of the
passage of the iija we have more money
in this federal fiscal year
um so there's more funding in 2022
and then in the window of the draft
10-year plan that you're looking 23
forward
so at this time we would anticipate
using the additional
apportionment that we're receiving for
fiscal year 22 and advancing that
project
before september
30th of this year
we're still
looking at other options that might be
available to us but that's the current
recommendation
thank you
representative ebel
i wanted to inform the chair that the
electric vehicle infrastructure program
is on page 204
uh the the roll out so could you just
remind but i have another question on
page nine where it says active
transportation can you remind me again
what that means i think you described it
but i don't quite
before i answer that question i just
want to circle back to the ev charging
program
so our formula funds the core highway
programs we have to obligate those
dollars every year one thing we should
point out about the new bridge program
the 225 million as well as the ev
charging is we get the money for a
five-year period so it's not the same
urgency to obligate
a certain amount each and every year we
can roll it forward and spend it at a
future date so that's why
we expect federal highway to focus on
guidance documents for the other
programs where you have to obligate
annually um the core formula programs
and then perhaps issue the guidance on
the ev charging piece so that there's
less urgency
we have really 17 million over five
years as opposed to having to manage an
annual apportionment so that takes the
pressure off a little bit
with respect to active transportation
it's
what we consider healthy transportation
options so walking and biking whether
that's incorporating
bike lanes and wider shoulders into our
on-road connections or investing in rail
trails and off system
infrastructure
thank you any other questions
if not i have a couple and they're all
off of
slide 20 of course
because we are going to have to deal
with some of these um first one the
tilton project
is that 3.25 million
currently in your general fund budget to
do that
yes that project was funded through the
budget process which is why we've
included it as general funded
thank you
um
the
dixville colebrook the golf links road
which is not included in the draft but
um i'm hearing a lot from various people
about it needs to be funded
if we
give any money
what type what color money would it have
to be and are we looking at a private
road or or a state road that we would
have to maintain forever
golflings road is currently state-owned
and what had been proposed in previous
10-year plans was that we would spend
state dollars to improve the roadway and
then turn it over to the balsams
because it really does serve that
property
and isn't part of the the greater
roadway network the challenge is this
roadway is not eligible for federal
funds it would have to be state funded
and as we touched on
during our last presentation
while we've received a lot of additional
federal funds through the iija our state
revenues have been impacted by the covid
pandemic and individuals just driving
less
so
it would be a challenge to fund this
project given the other
okay i
thought that was the answer that was
going to be
state highway funds and if we do this we
have to
either not plow as often in the winter
or or dropped some other project
something i'm i'm being semi-sarcastic
but
it really comes down to those kinds of
choices if i'm right
our highway funds are limited
so yes those were the types of choices
if you wanted to use highway funds
you know although we would defer to the
legislature you know general funds are
being used for calif road so
of course there's other funds that are
not typically used by the dot that could
and the decision not to include the the
in the last 10-year plan the department
had been given the authorization to work
with the town of hudson
um as they advanced the design of
it would not be the circumferential
highway it really would be
a boulevard within the
right-of-way that had been secured
for the circumferential highway
during this 10-year plan period we
didn't hear any advocacy from the town
of hudson and since it was not a dot
project it was a town-led project where
we were just granted the authorization
to partner with them and to review their
design et cetera
it's not currently included in this 10
year plan
thank you
any other questions
seeing none
thank you very much and we look forward
to working with you over
uh the next couple of weeks as we we
discuss the
the uh 10-year plan
for the members we will be meeting next
week we do have at least one more
speaker today
but as you go through the book and and
these slides
if you want to
ask questions bring them in
so that we can get them answered if you
think you're going to change something
be willing to say what you're willing to
give up someplace else to do them
it's a zero-sum game as far as money
goes
so if you move something up be able to
tell me and and the department what you
want to move back
we don't want those arguments but but it
really is
i you know i kind of make fun of that
but every year we have people come in
and want to advance something or add
something
but
are not willing to
say what they want to change what they
want to drop in order to pay for it
when i first came here
the 10-year plan was over a billion
dollars over subscribed
it took us years to get it down to
fiscally constrained as much as possible
and i as chairman and i thank all the
veteran members want to keep it that way
because if you put it on the 10-year
plan somebody thinks it's actually going
to get done
at some point
but if you're a billion dollars over
you never know what's going to happen so
as you look through and i'm not trying
to say don't bring in amendments to
change things or or whatever but it's up
to us to to manage that so commissioner
thank you very much for today do you
and we'll just work with you mr chairman
to prepare materials for the work
sessions so any questions that the
committee members have feel free to
reach out to us
through the chair or directly
and then we'll continue to confer with
the chair on content for our future
presentations
again thank you
um
mr nathan miller southern new hampshire
planning commission who is in support of
while he's taking a seat i would remind
everybody that we have been receiving
public testimony
electronically from some of the other
regional planners and
citizens and the rest all of that should
be reviewed and taken into consideration
as we go through our work sessions
and
our final deliberations
thank you welcome mr miller
thank you very much mr chairman members
of the committee again my name is nathan
miller i am the deputy director of the
southern new hampshire planning
commission we are one of the nine
regional planning commissions we serve
14 communities including and surrounding
the city of manchester in the southern
part of the state
i am here today just to express my
support
on behalf of the southern new hampshire
planning commission for the draft
2023-2032 10-year plan
as it has been
presented by gasset and recommended to
you by the governor
the 10-year plan is a strong partnership
between regional planning commissions
and the department of transportation we
work closely together to ensure that
regional priorities are included in the
plan given prevailing state and federal
financial constraints and we in our
region are pleased with how the region's
priorities are reflected in this draft
10-year plan
i just want to briefly hit a couple of
highlights in our region that are of
note uh in this 10-year plan i won't get
too far into the minutia and i'll keep
it uh short
uh but i i do want to start with a an
acknowledgement uh of of all of the
effort that has happened over many years
between new hampshire department of
transportation with the support of the
legislature to
construct and bring to completion the
expansion of i-93 from salem to
manchester
that the completion of that project
is a milestone not just for southern new
hampshire but for the state as a whole
we are appreciative in our region that
that project is is a 10-year plan
and that will require
attention um obviously all debt service
does
so in this 10-year plan uh having said
that
that one of the major projects on the
horizon in our region is exit 4a in
derry and londonderry and this draft
10-year plan does include full funding
for the completion of the exit 4a
project with construction scheduled to
occur
from 2023 to 2025. we thank the
department of transportation and the
legislature for your continued support
of this project
and we look forward to the mobility and
economic development benefits the
project will have for both dairy and
londonderry and beyond
for our regional planning commission the
southern new hampshire planning
commission uh we did not add any new
projects in this 10-year plan update
what we did with our regional allocation
is we took a hard look
in the existing 10-year plan and we
identified two projects in our region
that we knew to be underfunded and we
committed our regional allocation to
help bring those projects to uh to full
funding
those projects are the expansion of
route three in bedford between hawthorne
drive and raymond was oreck drive a very
important project not only for the town
of bedford but our region as a whole
and the second project was in the town
of londonderry the intersection
improvements at new hampshire route 28
and 128 if you're familiar with the town
of londonderry in that intersection
we focused our entire regional
allocation on those two projects and and
thankfully with the support of of new
hampshire d.o.t i'm pleased to report
that both of those projects are fully
funded in this draft 10-year plan
and so we are uh very thankful for that
uh i i think in in uh in the remarks a
few minutes ago from the commissioner
and and pete stamnis i i want to echo
um the that the covid pandemic has
altered traffic patterns and has
resulted in lower revenue projections
for
a number of state revenue sources
perhaps most notably the toll revenue
projections for turnpike system revenues
are
are lower because of the covid 19
pandemic
we appreciate the way that the dot has
has navigated this period of of revenue
uncertainty nobody could have predicted
the pandemic when we were testifying on
the last 10 year plan a couple of years
ago
in this very room
and so we certainly thank the department
for their efforts on that
that said as a result of the lower toll
revenue projections the 10-year plan
does include timeline delays for a
couple of very significant and important
turnpike projects in our region
most notably
the reconstruction of exit six and seven
in the city of manchester
as well as the expansion of the effie
everett turnpike between nashua and
bedford both of those projects seeing
timeline delays as a result of those
lower revenue projections
there's not a lot we can do about that
at this point but that said both of
these projects continue to enjoy strong
local support within our region
they have substantial safety and
congestion benefits for our region and
and we would ask that
in the event that any new or unexpected
revenue comes available and i say that
often but in the last couple of years
there has been new and unexpected
revenue uh so in the event that any more
of that comes to fruition we would
appreciate consideration for those two
projects on the turnpike system to help
get those back to their their
pre-pandemic construction timelines
and additionally as
the commissioner mentioned there are a
number of discretionary programs that
have been established in the new
iija the new infrastructure
and jobs act
if any of those discretionary programs
may be an appropriate fit for one or
both of these projects we at the at the
southern new hampshire planning
commission would certainly be willing to
assist in any way we can to develop a an
application for for funding to help uh
support the the construction of those
projects through a discretionary program
if that was deemed to be beneficial so
with that i will uh yield back to you mr
chairman and i appreciate the uh the
time of the committee to to speak to you
all today and and express my support for
the plan
any questions from members of the
committee
seeing none thank you
that was the only other pink card that i
had
is there anybody who has not spoken on
house bill 2022 who would like to speak
at this time
has anybody spoken who would like to
speak a second time
see none
i will close the public here
excuse me recess the
public hearing on house bill 2022
there will be a continued
session of the public hearing on
february 10th
so
i
the committee is in recess on house bill
2022.
sort of an announcement type thing yeah
let me let me finish it i i want to
thank everybody for being here please
clear off
um all of your your papers and
everything other committees are meeting
in this room for the rest of the week
no
yeah thank you i just like to remind
everyone the purpose of the microphones
is not so people in the room can hear it
so people on the live stream can hear
so if the red light in front of you is
not on the people watching cannot hear
you
josh
yeah just so for planning purposes how
long do you expect
us to go on the next two meetings i know
we start at 9 30 but just time wise
okay when you get the calendar this week
you'll find that next week's
on the 27th
at 9 30 we will have the continued
public hearing
on
on the road usage and then hopefully
that will be short
and then start in on
discussions of various projects whether
or not
we think that they should be where they
are or whatever
i would say probably about this same
amount of time time not later
and
if we have some time i would like to
in the morning
of that day
so that we can
[Music]
finish up with with bills that we have
and get it into the calendar for the
house session in mid-february
i'm
working towards having
all of our work done by mid-february
we can
get the 10-year plan over to the senate
let them start working on it
and
maybe go skiing or something fun
all right any questions or comments
representative edgar
uh thank you mr chairman um i might have
heard you're wrong i'm just
this is going to reconvene on the 27th
of january no february
[Music]
the continued public hearing on house
bill
2022 will be on february 10th
next week we have
the next two weeks we have committee
work sessions on house bill 2022 which
is
work within the committee
on what we've heard
what we've heard from constituents what
we've get over that electronically on
what needs to be changed they're not
changed within the 10-year plan
so that's our work sessions not public
thank you mr chairman
seeing no one else um thanks everybody
for coming oh representative claudia
now if you can answer this what bills do
you anticipate as of today or have you
made up your mind which you would like
to exact next week you have any ideas i
would like to exact all of them except
correct because
you know if we get mired in in disputes
on one or two of them um we can defer
that but we can't defer them forever
and and if we have to i
don't really want to come in an extra
day just to exact two or three bills
none of our bills are early bills our
deadline
is march 17th is the last day to act on
you